I've just found out that the Four
Seasons Inn is about as far away from a
luxury hotel as you can get I need to
find out what's really going on here
how are you about five months I came
here to do like massage therapy and
stuff but then we didn't have like I
really call for it so it's slow so I
just started housekeeping you ever stay
here I do are you doing yeah I live here
how does that work
salary wise I mean I don't get one would
you mean I get one I've never gone a
paycheck you're joking
yeah so you're gonna get to ask about it
uh-huh I'm not wicked excited about not
getting a paycheck but I don't have a
full-on conversation with sandy about it
because I am scared that he's going to
yell at me and I just don't want to take
it gone so how can you treat this place
professionally if you're not getting
paid you can't really I guess for you
know calm no yeah
let see how yeah no one gets paid what
embarrassment take it
I can't believe sandy doesn't pace
housekeeper no wonder one room was such
a mess I hope the food here is better
than the rooms it's lonely in here where
the hell is everybody
hello hello my name is Gwen Gwen nice to
see where do you pop out off to the
kitchen I'm gonna get you started with
the glass of water here that's where she
kind of runs the house here you haven't
met her yet yeah she seems busier than
the owner entrees
I'll have the mushroom ravioli it sounds
delicious let's go for the salmon as
well after that cut with apples finished
with maple glaze and a Apple risotto you
would like that over soda okay great all
right man I'm so nervous I'm drying out
to get I puked last night before service
and after service and I'll probably do
the same tonight our risotto with the
sin and sin seared not cooked through
he's got a baby I think we're gonna
knock our socks off with the food all
right well we have some bread for you
what do you think yeah disgusting it's
just so heavenly I'm doing hey curry
bread you'll eat anything
Gordon did not approve of the curry
bread a large sandy being a business
owner with no culinary experience or
training in any way I'll say last night
it's doughy I don't feel that he should
be back in the kitchen working done
stay with me girl sunny carry Brett I'm
hoping these things good with issues are
at least visible sand it flavor
flavorful I'm sure there's going to be a
lot of flavor here mushroom ravioli the
dog does throw up on my plate I hope not
Wow how is it are the passes undercooked
just saw her thank you sorry no it's not
your fault what's the main problems with
this place um management I mean the
management is sandy right yeah I've
worked for him and haven't received
checks
stuff of worked hard you're not being
paid yeah Wow jeez that's tough sandy
can be extremely hard to work with and
for bizarre and weird good god of can
this get any worse
he said it's undercooked okay all food
in house right now that is coming off of
this menu none of it is local none of it
is fresh Sandy's menu is garbage oh good
good afternoon customer right Richard Oh
Richard I'm sorry first time we met I'm
Richard you know a customer would you do
I work with Sandy on ideas from
marketing when was the last big idea you
put into the full seasons last big idea
we had was purchasing lift tickets at a
discounted rate right I would have
followed you five months ago coming into
the summer what's the next big plan and
I can present plenty of plenty of ideas
but he has to accept them I'm frustrated
I feel that the ideas I bring to him are
helpful they would work but sandy he's
just not listening and here's your
salmon excellent thank you what I enjoy
thank you thank you good god I hope it's
at least half way good Apple risotto
wow what a pile of [ __ ] that sums it up
on that play there he's as good as chef
as either an innkeeper [ __ ] useless I
can't believe I've not seen sandy once
through my whole meal
what sort of ink even aussies guests and
hides in the kitchen well if you won't
come to me just give me that no for now
hi guys hi I'm Steve Dixon Steve good to
see you but yeah well good to see you
too but I'm trying to get a grasp on
what I've just eaten I know you're the
owner yes but you're the head chef as
well buzz we're working together now
into him
so you're both had chefs I'm not I'm not
exactly sure where I fit in it's not my
menu I'm not doing any ordering filled
with Cindy right now a little thrown
under the bus I feel a little betrayed
right now the risotto was sweet with
what's in there apple juice apple
concentrate sure Apple concentrate in a
risotto yes sir come on it's about my
menu chef so this is all you're doing
then oh my god I just have five minutes
on it on my own with the owner would you
mind yes sure no how do you expect stop
magical words coming out of a [ __ ]
can
twenty-three fourteen years I wait they
give them [ __ ] apple juice
concentrate I just feel absolutely
destroyed my food is so much better than
what I just [ __ ] gave Gordon if you
know how am I gonna go home and face my
kids when they're all proud of me and
I'm like you look at dog food you know
that's not why I became a chef who in
this room actually gets paid
[Music]
that's why there's no standards because
nobody's getting paid so there's no
responsibilities if you pay peanuts you
get monkeys have you paid nothing
you get bahcall zero it's our business
it's a [ __ ] joke
talk to me sandy obviously wasn't well
we started off with all the good
intentions and we've had every bump in
the road but when we started out we
started out wonderfully stop it
it's an embarrassment stop the lies
there's no lies but you were not booming
when you first opened her it out nobody
believes it sandy where's your market if
there's nothing to market so what have
you done oh god sakes man please